[Applaus]
[Musik]
der nahostkonflikt ist die ultimative
unendliche geschichte eine geschichte
mit vielen akteuren einer menge
komplexität wohl eine handlung die sich
seit der gründung des staates israel im
jahr 1948 in einer wahrlich zermürbenden
dauerschleife befindet mehr als 70 jahre
sind vergangen und wir befinden uns
quasi noch immer in der gleichen
situation
es stimmt zwar dass sich die beziehungen
israels zu vielen arabischen ländern in
rasantem tempo verbessern aber in der
palästinenserfrage sind die dinge immer
noch so angespannt wie festgefahren wie
eh und je
das territorium israels welches nur 23
prozent des ehemaligen britischen
mandatsgebiet palästina umfasst wurde
immer wieder geteilt und neu aufgeteilt
was zu einer komplexen landkarte mit
einerseits mehrheitlich jüdischen und
andererseits mehrheitlich muslimischen
enklave geführt hat die kaum miteinander
verbunden sind
dieser mangel an territorialen
zusammenhalt führt auch die komplexität
auf politischer und sozialer ebene
besonders in den teilen die derzeit von
vielen muslimischen araber und
kontrolliert werden
die sich seit ein paar jahrzehnten als
palästinenser bezeichnet der westbank
und dem gazastreifen und damit wären wir
auch schon beim ersten protagonisten
dieses videos dem gazastreifen
im jahr 2005 nach abschluss des
israelischen rückzugs plans der vom
damaligen premierminister ariel scharon
vorangetrieben wurde
und übrigens den abzug von truppen liter
kosten und den abbau von 21 israelischen
zivil siedlungen beinhaltet gegen gaza
zur selbstbewertung über nachdem es
jahrzehntelang erst von den lippen und
dann von israel kontrolliert worden war
zunächst bildete die gruppierung haben
aus einer einheitsregierung mit der
fatah der größten politischen partei der
palästinensischen araber
doch diese politische ehe hielt nicht
mal ein ganzes jahr seitdem hat sich das
verhältnis zwischen fatah und hamas
immer weiter verschlechtert unter
anderem deshalb weil beide die kontrolle
über die gebiete beanspruchen die von
der anderen seite kontrolliert werden
zwischen 2006 und 2011 herrscht echte
bürgerkriegs zustände zwischen den
beiden fraktionen in den strassen von
gaza schießereien bewaffnete
zusammenstöße das gegenseitige lünschen
sport führern und anhängern gezielte
attentate entführungen es wird geschätzt
dass dabei mehr als 1000
palästinensische araber zu tode kamen
da sache ist dass die claims der beiden
streithähne am ende aufgeteilt wurden im
grunde genommen wurde der hamas die
politische und militärische kontrolle
über den gaza streifen überlassen
während die fatah die kontrolle über das
westjordanland übernahmen aber das war
bei weitem nicht das einzige problem
denn die hamas ist eine rechte
terrorgruppe mit dschihadistischem und
anti zionistische ideologie es reicht
ihr nicht dass wie bereits gesagt 77
prozent des ehemaligen mandatsgebiet
palästina unter arabischer kontrolle vor
allem der das königreich jordanien
stehen nein ihnen sind selbst die 23
prozent die heute den staat israel
ausmachen ein dorn im auge sie wollen
nämlich 100 prozent für die araber und
0% für die juden die hammers startete
deswegen einen vernichtungskrieg gegen
israel in die vaters so jedoch nicht
unterstützt
seitdem traf die hamas relativ häufig
israel an durch raketenbeschuss mit
führungen und eine reihe anderer
operation um all das zu kontextualisiert
was wir in diesem video erzählen werden
ist es wichtig im hinterkopf zu behalten
dass es die den gazastreifen beherrscht
hamas ist die sich im krieg mit israel
befindet nicht die verdacht welche die
arabisch palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde und den großteil sowohl
des arabisch palästinensischen
territoriums als auch der bevölkerung
kontrolliert
[Musik]
neben der hamas gibt es noch den
arabisch palästinensischen islamischen
dschihad eine weitere gruppe die
ebenfalls raketen aus dem gaza-streifen
und manchmal sogar aus dem
westjordanland auf israel abfeuert und
dann gibt es noch eine vom iran
finanzierte schiitische gruppe die
hisbollah die israels preis von libanon
aus mit raketen bombardiert dass nicht
bevölkerte gebiet der israelischen küste
wird also regelmäßig von der hamas
bombardiert die ein territorium von 365
quadratkilometern und mehr als zwei
millionen einwohnern kontrolliert und
andererseits auch islamischen dschihad
oder da hilf du kannst dir also sicher
ziemlich einfach vorstellen es ist
anders ist dieser bedrohungslage lebens
richtig und was sichtbar und parität
nummer eins für israels
sicherheitskräfte ist die
fortschrittlichsten verteidigungssysteme
zu entwickeln
[Musik]
denn in diesem fall handelt es sich
weder um ein spiel noch um eine
potentielle rein hypothetische bedrohung
sondern um die knallharte realität der
tod von oben ist fester bestandteil des
israelischen alltags denn ohne überlegen
abfangsysteme läge die zahl der zivilen
israelischen todesopfer während dieses
permanenten krieges jenseits von gut und
böse
schließlich ist ja das erklärte ziel
dieser terrorgruppen ein juden freies
palästina das heißt der millionenfache
völkermord und hier kommt unser zweiter
protagonist ins spiel das vielleicht den
wichtigsten verteidigungssystem der edf
der israel defense forces oder zumindest
das wichtigste in jüngster zeit der
sogenannten
daher wollen wir in diesem video alles
wichtige über den wahrscheinlich
fortschrittlichsten raketenschild der
welt vorstellen
woraus er besteht wie er funktioniert
und wo vorher schützt also schnallt euch
an
denn jetzt geht's los
der raketen regen
ich sag's der eine ist ein wahres
wunderwerk der militärtechnologie zum
beispiel ist in der lage sich prozent
der raketen abzufangen
die von der hamas und den islamischen
jihad aus dem gazastreifen abgefeuert
werden und eines christen glauben das
ist wahrlich keine leichte aufgabe
die überwiegende mehrzahl der raketen
die derzeit von diesen organisationen
verwendet werden haben eine reichweite
von weniger als 100 kilometern
ihre größe variiert von kleinraketen die
kürzer als ein meter sind bis zum
richtig dicken wo man von drei meter
länge
wir sprechen zum beispiel von den kassen
raketen der ist syrien hergestellten
reiber en 302 und den iranischen vater
fünf athleten letztere kann die hammers
dank technologietransfers aus den iran
direkt in gaza herstellen daneben
bombardieren sie israel auch mit weniger
starken verschicken die zum beispiel nur
eine reichweite von knapp zwei
kilometern haben nur 90 zentimeter lang
sind und nicht besonders etwas sind
meist haben sie nicht einmal leitsysteme
aber auch diese sehr sehr kleines ziel
muss es anfangs system blitzschnell
identifizieren und zerstören also wie
genau es in die angriffe aus wie werden
diese raketen abgefeuert nun die
wahrheit ist dass es sich nicht um die
fortschrittliche technologie der welt
handelt in der tat ist es sehr einfach
diese raketen zu starten sie werden auf
einer startrampe platziert und die stadt
neigung und die benötigte
treibstoffmenge werden entsprechenden
ziel berechnet das ist aber keine
raketenwissenschaft wenn sie zum
beispiel tel aviv angreifen wollen dass
etwa 70 kilometer expert ist brauchen
sie einen höheren winkel und mehr
treibstoff als wenn sie angreifen wollen
das nur etwa 20 kilometer von gaza
entfernt ist
aber wie du siehst ist das alles das
genaue gegenteil eines präzisions
schlags bei dem es um die gezielte
ausschaltung eines militärischen ziels
und die maximale schonung von zivilisten
geht was diese raketen also besonders
gefährlich für die zivilbevölkerung
macht ist die tatsache dass im grunde
weder die hamas noch der islamische
dschihad noch in israel noch
irgendjemand anders weiß wo genau sie
einschlagen werden diese raketen sind
völlig willkürliche terrorist momente
sie könnten entweder in einem weizenfeld
landen oder direkt ein wohngebäude
treffen daher ist ist die aufgabe ist
ein dom zu verhindern dass diese raketen
überhaupt nirgendwo auf den boden
aufzeichnet denn abgesehen von
menschenleben richtet ja ein derartiges
flächenbombardement auf erhebliche
wirtschaftliche schäden an
ich schaue jetzt zum beispiel mal diese
grafik an daran sich zu dem vergleich
zwischen zwei jahren 2006 und 2014 in
denen eine ähnliche anzahl von raketen
auf israel abgefeuert wurde zuerst von
bexbach im jahr 2006 und später von der
hamas im jahr 2014 im jahr 2006 als die
eisenkuppel der einen daumen noch nicht
in betrieb war liefen sich die schäden
durch raketen anschläge auf 195
millionen dollar im jahr 2014 als die
kuppel bereits in betrieb war
beliefen sich die schäden ohne
systemkosten auf 29 millionen dollar
selbst wenn wir die kosten für den
betrieb des raketenschildes
berücksichtigen würde sich die rechnung
im jahr 2014 auf 111 millionen dollar
belaufen etwa 80 millionen dollar
weniger als der schaden diesmal auch
allein im jahr 2006 verursacht haben
natürlich ist das aber nicht das
wichtigste
[Musik]
offensichtlich ist das wichtigste wie
man das risiko reduziert dass eine
dieser raketen oder flugkörper in einem
wohnviertel oder einem büroturm landet
und menschen töten
übrigens nur als kleine randnotiz nach
internationalem recht ist das liebe
nachfolge von raketen gegen zivilisten
ein kriegsverbrechen
und auch wenn viele dies am liebsten
ausblenden oder relativieren würden der
wahllosen beschuss der zivilbevölkerung
mit raketen stellt eben nicht nur eine
schwere militärische aggression da
sondern auch ein ungeheures
kriegsverbrechen ich betone die ist
deswegen so ausdrücklich weil auch viele
journalisten die sich selbst für seriös
halten diesen punkt einfach ignorieren
oder auf unverantwortliche weise
verharmlosen aber zurück zum thema
wusstest du dass allein zwischen dem
zehnten und 13 mai 2021 israel mit mehr
als 1200 raketen angegriffen wurde
es handelte sich dabei um nichts
geringeres als den größten ag ein
anderes ende der geschichte des arabisch
israelischen konflikts und der daumen
ist dabei tatsächlich auf die bisher
extremste weise an seine grenzen
gestoßen schau dir einfach die nackten
zahlen an
von diesen 1300 raketen haben ist nur
etwa 200 geschafft auf den israelischen
boden auf zu kommen weitere 200 sind
noch im gazastreifen eingeschlagen
aufgrund von abschluss gelang
unterm strich bedeutet dies dass der
iron dome etwa 900 raketen in drei tagen
zerstört haben muss und hier kommt ein
wichtiges detail denn genau an dieser
stelle werden einige leute behaupten
dass die raketen aus gaza eigentlich
keine ernste bedrohung darstellen würden
weil naja weiß ich es sie haben ende
sowie suchen nicht bis auf den
israelischen boden schaffen würden aber
warum feuert die hamas dann tausende von
raketen auf israel innerhalb eines so
kurzen zeitraums nun genau deswegen weil
der iron dome so unglaublich effektiv
ist die hammers weist nun mal dass sie
riesiges halfen mit unglaublich vielen
raketen gleichzeitig abfeuern muss um
die kapazität des verteidigungssystems
zu überlasten
gut dass wenigstens ein paar ihrer
raketen durchkommen und schaden und über
israel bringen können wir haben es hier
also keineswegs mit einem harmlosen
feuerwerk ein paar verzweifelter
teenager zu tun so und an dieser stelle
fragt ihr euch jetzt alle sicher wieder
ein dom eigentlich funktioniert welche
erkennungssysteme verwendet er wie viel
das gekostet ihn zu bauen und wie viel
kostet der laufende betrieb und einsatz
genau das sehen übrigens jetzt mal aus
der nähe
[Musik]
israels schutzschild der einsam wurde
2011 installiert und in betrieb genommen
der grund warum er entwickelt wurde war
kein geringerer als die zunehmende
häufigkeit und raffinesse der
raketenangriffe die zwischen 2000 und
2010 von der hamas und der hisbollah
gegen israel durchgeführt wurden und wie
sich zeigte war die entwicklung alles
andere als eine schlechte idee gewesen
denn das system hat bisher aber tausende
von raketen abgefangen
entwickelt wurde es von raphael advanced
defense systems und service industries
einem bald vielleicht sogar
börsennotierten unternehmen der
israelischen luftfahrt und militär
austria auch du kannst dann ein dock
aktien kaufen und von wahrscheinlich
großartigsten werke der israelische
militär industrie ihrem flaggschiff
tieren kronjuwel profitieren denn wie du
dir vorstellen kannst ist das alles
nicht gerade billig die israelische
regierung hat geschätzte 100 millionen
dollar ausgegeben und zwar für jede
einzelne batterie bzw untereinheit des
systems davon sind derzeit 10 in betrieb
mit plänen diese zahl auf 15 zu erhöhen
mit anderen worten wir reden hier über
ein system dass mindestens eine
milliarde dollar kostet und wie
funktioniert es nun schauen sie einfach
mal das folgende bild an
[Musik]
jede batterie besteht aus drei bis vier
abschussrampen jeweils mit 20 turnieren
lenkraketen ausgestattet sind eine tanne
ist drei meter lang 90 kilo schwer und
zwar inklusive des elf kilogramm
schweren splitter gefechtskopf weitere
grundlegende elemente sind das em 284
radar und das bmc das battle management
and controls ist die drei elemente das
heißt die raketenwerfer das radio und
das kontrollsystem sorgen für das
reibungslose funktionieren des ganzen
systems das ganze läuft dann im grunde
so aber dass radler erkennt eine
bedrohung abheben
normalerweise in form von raketen oder
sogar drogen und dann bezieht das bieten
sie den abschluss der lenker klicken
deren aufgabe es ist die bedrohung in
der luft zu zerstören diese sind im ziel
mit hilfe ihres integrierten radar sucht
ein eigenes steuer- leitwerk verleiht
der tami außerdem jene aus dem zeichen
der manövrierfähigkeit welche sie in die
lage versetzt anderer ketten punktgenau
und erfolgreich anzusteuern
und sobald sie das integrations
reichweite ist löst ernährungs zünder
aus gefahr gebannt das system benötigt
in der regel eine tanne rakete pro
objekt aber manchmal sind auch mehrere
notwendig es kann dabei simultan eine
vielzahl gleichzeitig gestartete rakete
abfangen
tja wie du siehst haben das alles in
allem mit der absoluten spitzenklasse
der verteidigungstechnik sind tun
aber damit du dir auch eine vorstellung
machen kannst wie kostspielig das ganze
ist jede tami rakete kostet zwischen
20.000 und 100.000 dollar im schnitt
etwa 50.000 in anderen worten um einen
angriff wie den in der zweiten maiwoche
2020 abzuwehren
bei den mindestens 1200 raketen auf
israel abgefeuert wurden entstehen
kosten von mindestens 55 millionen
dollar allein für termin raketen die
neutralisierung aller 4000 bis zum
waffenstillstand abgefeuerten
hamas-raketen dürfte gar 200 millionen
dollar gekostet haben was die reichweite
angeht so kann jede batterie ein gebiet
von etwa 150 quadratkilometern
verteidigen und hat eine reichweite von
etwa 70 kilometern
das heißt eine einzige batterie ist in
der lage eine mittelgroße stadt komplett
zu schützen
und dies ist der hauptgrund warum
derzeit zehn batterien im einsatz sind
und bald sogar 15
jede einheit des landes ist tag und
nacht einsatzbereit unter allen
witterungsbedingungen
die einheiten sind dabei extrem mobil
auf spezialfahrzeugen angebracht oder
auf schiffen der israelischen marine
ihre position innerhalb israels oder gar
auf see kann so ständig verändert werden
dadurch ist es für den feind praktisch
unmöglich die einen dom einheiten zu
lokalisieren und auszuschalten
aufgrund der hohen kosten für die
batterie wird ein dom jedoch nur in
bewohnten gebieten eingesetzt
einer der wichtigsten vorteile dabei man
kann sich damit zeit erkaufen extrem
wertvolle zeit überzeuge dich selbst
indem du einen blick auf diese karte
wirst ein israeli der neben den
gazastreifen wohnt hat im falle eines
angriffs nur 50 sekunden zeit sich in
einem bunker zu flüchten dieser zeit
erhöht sich auf etwa 30 sekunden wenn
man in aschkelon lebt 45 sekunden in
arnstadt und etwa 90 sekunden in tel
aviv oder jerusalem dh in der zeit die
du gerade damit verbracht hast du den
letzten satz man zuhören hättest du es
bereits bis in einem schutzraum schaffen
müssen wenn du in aschkelon wohnst und
die sirene ertönt und in den dom neun
von zehn raketen abfängt und zerstört
ermöglicht er menschen auch einen
größeren spielraum sich an einen
sicheren ort zu beginnen er ist wie eine
art schutzengel vergleichbar mit ein
torwart der am himmel operiert und
versucht die bälle davon abzuhalten
ein haus oder ein geschäft zu treffen
aber natürlich haben wir es in diesem
fall nicht mit bällen zu tun sondern mit
etwas viel viel gefährlicheren so
funktioniert also dieses muss
ganz system dass israels himmel morgens
mittags und abends schützt also mehr
über israels armee und warum sie so
unglaublich effektiv ist erfahren
möchtest klicks auf das video oben
rechts verrate uns aber bitte vorher was
du selbst über den iron dome längst
glaubst du zum beispiel dass seine hohe
effektivität israels feinde dazu bringen
könnte vom raketenbeschuss auf eine
andere art der bedrohung umzuschwenken
schreib uns deine meinung bitte in die
kommentare
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat falls jahr geht uns bitte
einen leid ist mit euren freunden und
vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren
machs gut shalom und bis bald
[Musik]